excellence is the most powerful answer
you can give to the doubters and the
haters life isn't fair and that's okay
Falls you'll love to be a streetsweeper
sweep streets like Michelangelo painted
pictures rise and shine it's expresso
time what's up believe nation itself in
my one word is believe and I believe in
you I believe you have an amazing gift
inside you that I want to see exploded
onto the world so let's start your day
off right together grab your coffee and
sip on today's message choose excellence
over to you Michelle Obama are you going
to throw up your hands and say that
progress will never come are you going
to get angry and lash out are you going
to turn inward and just give in to
despair and frustration or are you going
to take a deep breath straighten your
shoulders lift up your head and do what
Barack Obama has always done as he says
when they go low I go high
that's the choice Barack and I have made
that's what has kept us sane over the
years we simply do not allow space in
our hearts minds or souls for darkness
instead we choose faith faith in
ourselves in the power of hard work
faith in our God whose overwhelming love
sustains us every single day that's what
we choose we choose love our love for
our children
our commitment to leaving them a better
world our love for our country which has
given us so many blessings and
advantages and love for our fellow
citizens parents working hard to support
their kids men and women in uniform who
risk everything to keep us safe young
people from the toughest backgrounds who
never stopped believing in their dreams
young people like so many of you that's
what we choose and we choose excellence
we choose the tune out all the noise and
strive for excellence in everything we
do no cutting corners no taking
shortcuts no whining
we give 120 percent every single time
because excellence excellence is the
most powerful answer you can give to the
doubters and the haters it's also the
most powerful thing you can do for
yourself because the process of striving
and struggling and pushing yourself to
new heights see that's how you develop
your god-given talents that's how you
make yourself stronger and smarter and
more able to make a difference for
others life isn't fair the family you're
born into the country you're born into
your religion your skin color your
gender there's a lot of very real things
that exist in this world a lot of very
real prejudices that hold people back
life isn't fair and chances are you
might not have the capital or the
education of the resources or the
parents of the family of the connections
or the right skin color or the right
gender any of these things you might not
have it all lined up for you perfectly
and so the next step is then what do you
respond to so yes you're right and then
what are you gonna be like what most
people do is they just complain they
complain that life isn't fair they
complain that they don't have the right
circumstances and then they become a
victim of those circumstances
or are you gonna take the more difficult
path the one of taking personal
responsibility personal accountability
and choosing excellence and saying I'm
gonna break free of this mole I'm gonna
break free of the circumstances that
were placed above me I'm gonna set my
own path I'm gonna make the world better
for myself and the people around me I'm
gonna choose excellence if you look at
the people that you love the people you
look up to the people that I've profiled
in this channel whoever your heroes are
your role models the people who you
aspire to be chances are they came from
nothing chances are they had tons of
odds stacked against them and they chose
excellence and that's why they want look
at Michelle Obama her father was an
employee at a city water plant her
mother was a secretary and then once she
had kids was a stay-at-home mom so
Michelle Obama is the daughter of a city
water plant employee and secretary turn
stayed home ah and chances are again
whoever you look up to they have a
similar story it's very very very rare
and I've covered lots of these people I
may have covered more than anybody
online I've covered lots of successful
people it's very very very rare that the
son or daughter of a great person goes
on to do great things themselves it's
very rare that the kids of people who've
done amazing things go on to do amazing
things themselves
it's very rare it doesn't happen that
often and you might think that sounds
crazy these kids of super successful
people have everything lined up for them
have the money the education the
resources all the time in the world
everything handed them on a silver
platter it's so easy for them to win and
that's why they don't win because you
win through the struggle because you win
by overcoming the odds because that's
how you develop excellence by going
after the difficult things the people
who have an easy life never win the
people will have a hard life and
overcome and choose excellence and drive
daily and refuse to be a victim of those
circumstances those are the people who
ultimately win and so that's you right
now if you you feel like the world is
unfair first of all you're right and
second there's a book there's a bunch of
things that are stacked against you
then I would highly highly highly
encourage you to surround yourself with
the stories of people who have made it
with the stories of people who look like
you who have the same background as you
who are the same circumstances as you
who made it because if they could make
it then you can too and most of the
people that I profiled most of the
people who've done videos on this
channel look at their stories chances
are they came from a worse upbringing
than what you have right now they had
less than what you have right now when
they started and one of my favorite
stories is Oprah Winfrey and she was so
poor growing up you know she grew up
without parents she grew up being abused
by her family she grew up with her
grandmother who had no money and put
together dresses made out of potato bags
can you imagine going to school in a
potato bag that was sewn into a dress
like how the ridicule would be from your
classmates at school wearing a potato
bag as a dress to school can you imagine
that
and look what Oprah went on to do are
you gonna tell me that you have a worse
upbringing what Oprah head or any of
your heroes spend the time don't look at
how Michelle Obama or Oprah Winfrey or
any of these people make an extra
million dollars right now
spend the time to look at their
backstory spend the time to understand
where they came from and when they chose
excellence and how it had a massive
difference and change of trajectory of
their life because if they could do it
you can too
you just have to decide that one life
isn't fair and that's okay and two I'm
gonna choose excellence I'm gonna stop
being a victim of my circumstances and I
decide to make things better for myself
for my community and for the people
around me now I've got some really
special bonus clips that I think you
guys are really going to enjoy but
before that I want to know what is one
area of your life that you have decided
to choose excellence in that you will no
longer tolerate average tolerate
mediocrity that you choose excellence
what is that one area
your life leave in the comments below
really curious to find that thank you
guys so much for watching I believe in
you I hope continue to believe in
yourself and whatever your one word is
much love I'll see you again tomorrow
morning for another shot of espresso and
enjoy the bonus clips
[Music]
you must have as a basic principle the
determination to achieve excellence in
your various fields of endeavor you're
going to be deciding as the days and the
years unfold what you will do in life
what your life's work will be and once
you discover what it will be set out to
do it and to do it well if it falls
you'll love to be a street sweeper sweep
streets like Michelangelo painted
pictures sweep streets like Beethoven
from Paul's music sweep streets like
leontyne price sings before the myths of
Metropolitan Opera and sweep streets
like Shakespeare wrote poetry sweep
streets so well that all the hosts of
heaven and earth will have to pause and
say here lived a great street sweeper
who swept his job well
[Applause]
if you can't be applying on the top of
the hill be a scrub in the valley but be
the best little scrub on the side of the
real be a bush if you can't be a tree if
you can't be a highway just be a trail
if you can't be the Sun be a star for it
isn't my size that you win or you fail
be the best of whatever you are for me I
would say it's all driven by curiosity
and the desire to be personally
challenged those two things I can sum up
sum it all up and I don't know if if
it's a it's if it's a formula for
success it's just what what drives me
very curious I want to know more I
choose projects that I'm going to learn
from I choose projects that are
challenging I don't want to do the same
thing twice so I think you know I think
personal challenge you know trying
trying to to strive for excellence and
to me that the in in filmmaking the
excellence is how excellent can the that
the entertainment experience be for the
audience and I'll pull out all all stops
to do that we've built like an
entrepreneurial ecosystem there that's
really empowered a lot of independent
thought leaders either in video
production or in blogging or in fashion
and in independent music and for me
looking at that pipe the pipe that that
serves a lot of this content and it's
kind of it's it's kind of pursuit of
excellence because it's very easy to
have gone the the cheap route on it and
we didn't took the hard route I think
that's one of the great achievements
raise your standard Apple at the cool
its core values is that we believe that
people with passion
not one drop of my self-worth depends on
your acceptance of me i don't ever give
up I'd have to be dead or completely
incapacitated
hey believe nation if you want to see my
all-time favorite top ten roses success
I have a very special secret video for
you these are the individual clips that
I have personally learned the most from
and applied to my life and my business
check the link in description for
details